ces tranchées dans le nord de la france
sont le symbole poignant du blocage
sanglant qui s'installa sur le front de
l'ouest pendant la grande guerre
malgré des efforts répétés et obstiné
par chacun des belligérants
aucun ne réussit une percée décisive ils
se trouvèrent entraîné pendant près de
quatre années dans une guerre d'usure
dont personne ne pouvait voir l'issue
et pourtant les premières semaines de la
guerre se déroulèrent d'une manière très
différente
à la fin de l'été et au début de
l'automne 2009 114 le front de l'ouest a
vu se dérouler des combats de mouvements
spectaculaires
c'est ainsi que huit jours après d'après
son arrivée en france le corps
expéditionnaire britannique s'est trouvé
confronté qu'ils allemand à la bataille
de monstres submergés par le nombre des
avants les tommies britannique tout
matière remarquablement meilleur
finalement reculé il s'ensuivit lui des
retraites les mieux exécuter de toute
l'histoire militaire en 13 jours
seulement
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
reculait de près de 400 kilomètres mais
sans perdre sa capacité à combattre des
adversaires beaucoup plus puissants et
nombreux
la bataille de mons la guerre de
mouvement
après plusieurs semaines d'hésitation
des politiques d'un grand bretagne
déclare a finalement la guerre à
l'allemagne le 4 août 1914 à travers
toutes les îles britanniques
des milliers de jeunes patriotes firent
la queue pour s'engager il voulait faire
leur part du boulot
servir le roi leur pays cinq jours
seulement après la déclaration de guerre
les premières troupes britanniques
commencé à arriver en france ce n'était
pas bien sûr ces jeunes engagés aussi
l'expérimenté qu'enthousiaste mais le
corps expéditionnaire qui était l'armée
régulière du pays est composée de
soldats professionnels endurcis on se
voit tous ces offres correct ya dix
semaines at elle insisté les français
dans leur profonde avec les allemands
tout en aidant même les belges à ceux
des forêts onf a raté leur mission était
d'empêcher les allemands d'avancer vers
bahreïn provoquant une mission
particulièrement importante que je
jouais en amont britannique avait mise
au point avec les français plusieurs
années avant le début de la guerre quand
soeur gones french qui commandait le
corps expéditionnaire s'est présenté aux
commandes en france est l'un des
officiers qu'il accueillir lui dit il
était grand temps guy arriviez le père
dont la guerre quand cela sera cause de
vous le corps expéditionnaire
britannique comptait quatre divisions
d'infanterie une division de cavalerie
elle et quelques aviateurs qui
composaient le royal fine cross ils
étaient divisés en deux unités
le premier corps a été commandée par le
lieutenant john drake et le deuxième
corps étaient sous les ordres du général
fils dorian qui venait d'en prendre le
commandement après l'avoir subi le 17
août
lille est en général grise
le tout sous les ordres du maréchal sort
john french maubeuge nous sommes ici
dans les faubourgs de maubeuge à
l'endroit où le corps expéditionnaire
avait d'abord réuni son avis
d'angleterre du 11 au 17 août 14
une fois rassemblés les imiter
avancèrent de 15 kilomètres jusqu'à la
ligne de front établi sur le canal entre
mons et courtrai et qu'elle avait pour
tâche de défendre à partir du 22 août
les britanniques investir la ville
minière de bon sens belgique et
s'installèrent sur le flanc gauche de la
5ème armée française qui était sous les
ordres du général lanrezac ce n'était
certes pas trop tôt
l'armée allemande s'était en effet mise
en route et son objectif de 28 ha par an
pour la seconde fois depuis 45 ans le
camp d'alpha et d'été de conquérir paris
pour en finir rapidement avec la france
tactiquement les allemands voulaient
traverser la belgique avec une harbi
considérable pour prendre ensuite à
robert paris et l'armée alliée
c'était le plan schlieffen du nom de son
auteur
quant à fred franck leconte afrique
votre iphone était le chef d'état-major
allemand des armées et début du siècle
il avait conçu le plan qui lui
permettraient de combattre ces deux
potentiels la russie alès et la france à
l'ouest il décida qu'il fait là bas
qu'est français d'abord en moins six
semaines l'attaquant travers les pays
bas et la belgique puis par une
manoeuvre de contournement sur la droite
d'encercler paris et de prendre à revers
l'armée française pour l'écraser comme
dans un étau une fois l'armée français
des frites
les français ne pourraient que capituler
début août 1914 trois corps d'armée
allemand totalisant plus de 250 mille
hommes passer la frontière et malgré de
résistance courageuse de l'armée belge
bruxelles suprise en cinq jours
le commandant en chef des forces
d'invasion était le général el votre vol
montre que c'était le neveu du grand bol
que l'homme qui avait conduit la
victoire écrasante de l'armée prussienne
sur la france pendant les guerres de
malheureusement patienter ils vendent
bol que junior n'étaient pas du même
calibre que ceux dont les quatre autres
corps d'armée qui composent l armée
allemande de l'ouest étaient déployés
dans un rôle défensif et se poser sans
difficulté au plan 17 c te le donner au
plan français qui prévoit lui un
dassault en force sur l'alsace et la
lorraine
le nom en du code du plan 17 étaient
force durable
cinq corps d'armée au lit le long du
fleuve étaient déployés et de les
glisser vers l'est pour reprendre
l'alsace le plan français est bien conçu
et l'erreur française avait été de ne
pas avoir fabriqué suffisamment
d'artillerie lourde
l'artillerie c'est la reine champ de
bataille et gagnent toutes les guerres
70% des pertes causées par l'artillerie
les allemands eux le savez bien il avait
beaucoup plu à retirer que les alliés
puis un petit cadeau de campagne jusqu'à
des eaux visé gigantesque devant les
difficultés rencontrées par impliquer
victorieusement le plan 17
le chef suprême des armées françaises le
général josef joffe ordres d'aude à son
flanc gauche de s'engager vers le nord
en belgique protégés sur sa gauche dans
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
enfin sauf à joffre su très vite que les
allemands réussirait à traverser très
rapidement la belgique ont dû prendre
une décision rapide
est-ce que je continue avec le plan dit
où est ce que j'en gagnais britannique
et l'armée française en belgique pour
affronter et bloquer l'avancée allemande
il pris la décision de réduire au
maximum son effort d'exécution du plan
on ne les sent qualifie minimum de
défense français pour lancer le maximum
de ses forces afin de bloquer le plan
schlieffen dès le 22 août
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
avait établi un front de 32km long du
canal mons condé
ça va de nos patrouilles de
reconnaissance aux crevettes au nord du
canal elle était constituée d'éléments
de risque hadrons c'est le 4e régiment
royal de dragon irlandais en tentant de
repérer l'armée allemande elle tombe sur
un certain nombre de cavaliers allemands
qui paraissent très nerveux et qui
refuse de s'engager contre la patrouille
décide de serbie tout de s'enfuir de 80
job à ce tire un coup de fusil qui était
probablement le tout premier coup de feu
tiré par le corps expéditionnaire
britannique en aiguille
le commandant du corps d'armée français
lanroze ac avait prévu initialement de
continuer à avancer
mais dans l'après midi saint john french
s'aperçut que les français avaient
changé leurs plans et corps d'armée qui
se trouvait à sa gauche à l'est était en
fait en train de se replier et c'était
le fonds britannique qui allaient subir
tout l'impact de l'assaut de la première
armée allemande de vente look en
laissant une note quand le général
french
je veux terminer le déploiement de ses
troupes autour d'eux il était clair que
lancera était déjà en fort retrait même
si un certain nombre de ces thrillers
tenté de retenir les allemands et le
général français n'avait pas d'autre
option que de reculer s'est rouvert une
posture défensive oms plus favorable
champlan nuit c'est que third jeune
frère avait déjà dépouillé ses effectifs
sur plusieurs kilomètres soldats avaient
creusé des tranchées les protections et
pris position pour essayer de ralentir
l'avancée allemande
french décida que compte tenu de
l'importance des forces allemandes qu'il
allait devoir affronter et lui était
impossible d'attaquer
par contre il assure au commandement
français qui défendrait ses positions
actuelles et qui les tiendra à l'est
moins 24 heures trois différences
de nos jours mon c'est une petite ville
active
mais le visiteur n'a pas aller bien loin
pour trouver les traces de la bataille
qui fit rage le dimanche 23 août 1914 le
paysage a beaucoup changé au cours des
dix années qui ont suivi la bataille ce
qui est maintenant une autoroute était
alors le cas d'al aux halles autour
duquel les combats firent rage
c'est tout particulièrement le cas du
saillant denis visite c'était comme une
protubérance qui rompait la ligne droite
que former normalement les canal et le
commandement britannique savait bien que
c'était un endroit vulnérables c'est le
tracé du canal où nous avions établi
notre défense et théodore de mons c'est
tony cannavino formé comme une crosse
d'éveil la partie logan continuer en
passant sous le pont condé est par ici
dans cet endroit l'espèce de crosse que
fera aimer le pont derrière molle
pandémie était défendu par lequel ce
bataillon les royalties et le pot à sa
droite du chemin de fer de haut et fort
était défendu par le 5e bataillon le
régiment du metal c'est les carreaux et
les crassiers des mines de charbon gêner
la ligne de tir des plus gros canons
britannique
il était clair que le succès du corps
expéditionnaire dépendrait du courage de
l'obstination de l'infanterie les
britanniques ont été extrêmement gêné
par le terrain pour de mons il ne savait
pas exactement où les allemands se
trouvait il n'en connaissait pas la
forbes
il ignorait où se trouvait le centre de
gravité de l'armée qui leur fait face
pour céder n'avait aucune idée de
l'endroit où les allemands contre
leur arnaque en bref c'est quand ils ont
découvert mon ce qu'ils ont réalisé
qu'on était loin du champ de bataille
idéal ce qu'ils avaient en face d'eux
n'avait rien à voir avec les terrains
entraînements ou les plaines sud
africaine dont quinze avaient l'habitude
les livres d'histoire des scream
l'endroit comme une caméra 3 milliards
qui sont tristes et son cartable petites
maisons de mineurs construit n'importe
comment
deux lanceurs des ruelles ma vie mons
était encombrée de nombreux véhicules
la ville était encore plein de civils et
aux vacances
le samedi les cloches sonnent et se
préparait à partir pour le bordelais
royaume en vacances il y avait une
attente il a le talent ils sont là
maintenant y'a rien à craindre et les
belges se battre est bien en belgique
tout ira bien
au matin du 23 août le corps
expéditionnaire britannique était prêt à
la bataille
à l'est le fond de mon sabre et était
tenu par le premier corps commander
pareil mais c'est le deuxième corps de
smith d'oriens qui subit le plus gros de
la tacc allemande qui commence à ce
matin à jerez ce jour là à mon sens on a
vu toute une série d'actions sur
lesquels les deux généraux dont eu
pratiquement aucun contrôle frêche se
trouvait à plusieurs heures de marche du
secteur s'est passé ce premier contact
quant au commandant allemand 25 lui
qu'il était trop loin lui aussi pour
diriger ses troupes qui pour la première
fois buté sur une véritable résistance
c'est un 2 heures du matin que les
premières salves de l'artillerie
allemande ont commencé à pleuvoir sur
les positions britanniques le long du
canal
une heure après l'infanterie allemande
commença à progresser
les hommes de royal fusiliers et ceux du
régiment du middlesex ont répliqué à
l'attaqué avec un tir d'infanterie
foudroyante de rapidité de précision
comme les allemands avancé en colonne
serré ils ont été fauchés par centaines
les allemands attaquent et en rangs
serrés
parce que cela impressionné
psychologiquement l'ennemi ils se
savaient plus nombreux et en avançant
comme un bloc compact il allait panique
et leurs adversaires les britanniques
ont été vraiment fasciné de voir les
allemands monter à l'assaut
un grand danger de fanta fin de 150
hommes marchant dans les champs les
soldats britanniques étaient les
meilleurs tireurs du monde ya cette
époque avait le meilleur fusil
le sml eux il était prêt si les gemmois
de 4 kg indexé l'amphi s'asseoir c'est
pour cela que les allemands ont perdu et
albert nobbs
ils ont même cru qu'ils écrivent sous le
feu de batterie de mitrailleuses ont
fait mais ce n'était pas le cas puisque
chaque régiment de disposer que de deux
mitrailleuses
la grêle de feu qui s'abattit sur les
allemands fut tel qu'il dure interrompt
pour leurs attaques pour sera organisée
une demi heure plus tard ils attaquèrent
sur un fond plus vaste et avec un
soutien leur artillerie à midi malgré
une résistance acharnée des britanniques
l'infanterie allemande réussi à
traverser le pont de bourg et à
s'emparer rapidement de deux autres
ponts situés à l'ouest
ce succès ne fut pourtant pas facile et
les allemands avaient subi de très
lourds de pair
on essaye ce qu'on a vu à mons a révélé
ce qui allait être le problème chronique
de toutes les attaques tentées au cours
de la première guerre mondiale quand on
a en face de soi des fusils et des
mitrailleuses bien déployer
défensivement il est très difficile aux
attaquants de gagner la partie
les tactiques utilisées des deux côtés
pendant la première guerre mondiale
était primitive on l'envoyait une masse
d'hommes qui ne pouvait avancer
lentement vers les fusils ennemis cette
forme d'offensive s'est avéré une et
technique et moins rentables de la
guerre et elle a tout et des pertes
considérables à chacun des adversaires
quand il attaquait à la bataille de mons
ça at il quand les allemands à l'ouest
du régiment du bild le sexe les hommes
des royals fizi les défend le pont du
chemin de fer de libye sans céder un
pouce de terrain pendant cinq longues
heures et malgré longue considérable de
leurs assaillants et l'absence de tout
support d'artillerie
ce fut là que se déroulent des actions
héroïques de la bataille le temps boris
10 qui commandait la mitrailleuse du
royal fusiliers reste à son poste pour
bloquer la vente de deux bataillons
d'infanterie allemande qui essayait de
prendre le pont dit ça a été blessé
plusieurs fois dans l'action mais il
refusait d'abandonner son barbe jusqu'à
ce que finalement les amis parviennent à
le tuer immédiatement le second gaz si
des godes les le remplaça et continue
habite raillé comme les défaillances de
break
gaudel et font toujours le pot et quand
le royal fille si elle reçoit l'ordre
d'aborder la position on lui demande de
rester en arrière sur le pont pour
couvrir la retraite avec ses servants il
accepte et très vite il est blessé
plusieurs fois il est encore
suffisamment valides pour jeter sa
mitrailleuse borloo pour la détruire et
ramper dans les fourrés vers la ville
deux civils
mais jusqu'à l'hôpital local de mons ont
c'est là qu'un peu plus tard dans
l'après midi il se retrouve prisonnier
des allemands qui ont réussi à prendre
la ville et qui le remède en captivité
car prévôté
on
pour leur héroïsme ce genre laboris 10 à
titre posthume dessinée god les ont
reçus tous deux les deux premières
victoria cross qui ont été distribués
pendant la première guerre mondiale
ailleurs le long du front établi sur les
cas d'al les combats les plus féroces
eurent lieu pour la prise des ponts à
l'est de saint gilles un les hommes du
1er régiment du western kent et ceux du
deuxième scratch bande heureuse repoussé
toutes les attaques même celle des fab'
grenadiers du brandebourg échouèrent
contre le feu nourri déficit britannique
aidée par l'artillerie de la 120e place
les tirs de la fonderie été si rapide et
précis que les grenadiers allemands ont
cru qu'il faisait face à un mur de
mitrailleuses betali
dans l'engagement ce terminal et prend
de boer avait perdu 500 hommes elway
scan tout juste cent un peu plus loin à
l'est aux herbes hier la tacc allemande
commence à une heure de l'après midi là
ce sont les hommes de l'is serait et
ceux du 2e régiment des rolls quantis
board heureuse qui sont parvenus à tenir
tout l'après midi
cependant à la fin de la journée les
positions britanniques étaient soumises
à une pression considérable
l'intention des allemands était de
prendre à revers tout le flanc alliés
grâce à cette attaque formidable de
l'ailé droite de l'armée devant le
constat est bien sûr comme les
britanniques n'étaient plus en contact
avec l'armée française
ils pouvaient facilement être contournée
encerclé et ruinent soeur john french
n'avait pas d'autre choix possible de
battre en retraite la retraite
britannique n'a pas été exécutée d'un
seul mouvement mais par une série de
décrochage successifs des deux heures de
l'après-midi le rgi borderolle fusiliers
commença sa retraite suivi une heure
plus tard dans le score de fusil
les scottish bande c'est le régime hors
de l'iss serait reculèrent à leur tour à
ce moment là le régiment royal du génie
entrepris de détruire les ponts qu'ils
avaient passé la journée à défendre cela
demande a beaucoup de courage et de
l'action valeureuse notamment mariette
ou une tentative courageuse mais sans
réussi de faire sauter le pont sous le
feu de l'ennemi valu une victoria cross
capitaine théodore ride tard dans
l'après-midi à bois le haut sur la route
darmigny à mons les allemands tenter un
dernier assaut c'est une position que tu
es le premier régiment gordon c'est le
deuxième régiment des royal scott
cette dernière attaque fut un désastre
supplémentaire pour les allemands qui
perd bien cinq officiers près de 400
fantassins en quelques minutes sous le
tir diaboliquement précis des troupes
britanniques
l'heure était venu d'arrêter des
attaques
monstre les britanniques n'ont pas subi
de pertes extrêmement lourdes amendes
par contre ce fut un véritable massacre
pour les allemands nous n'avons pas de
chiffres précis des pertes allemandes
mais je pense que moins 5000 d'entre eux
furent tués ou blessés
pour la première fois les allemands
avaient affronté l'armée britannique sur
un champ de bataille
ça leur a donné quoi réfléchir c'est un
véritable choc de réaliser que cette
petite armée méprisable comme l'avait
dit l'empereur n'était finalement pas si
méprisable que ça les allemands ont
appris à moins qu'il n'ait pas foncer
sur les alliés et les détruire en une
seule bataille
ils ont découvert que la force de
résistance des positions défensives et
estelle qu'il leur faudrait compter avec
des pertes considérables
quant aux britanniques ils se sont rendu
compte qu'ils étaient passés bien freiné
les encaissements et la suite de la
bataille de mons sera pris la grande
difficulté qu'il y avait à faire une
retraite en bon ordre
levant un ennemi conquérant
tôt dans la matinée du 24 août les
forces britanniques
exténué commencèrent à fortifier leur
position à cinq kilomètres au sud de
mons mais pendant la nuit sur john
french fut informé que la 5ème armée
française se replier vers le sud oise
matin pendant la soirée qui suivit la
bataille
les britanniques qui n'avait aucune
intention de continuer à reculer il
pensait en fait avoir stoppé net les
allemands bien sûr il avait dû faire un
repli stratégique de quelques kilomètres
mais la ligne de défense qui devenait
rétablir leur paraissait tout à fait
défendable mais pendant la nuit de
nouvelles informations arrivèrent trop
commandement britannique
le lieutenant spears qui était
l'officier de liaison à lons elle
reflète la 5ème armée française sur john
french comprit vite qu'il fallait que le
corps expéditionnaire bas immédiatement
en retraite faute de quoi il avait un
vrai danger d'être rapidement encerclés
par les allemands c'est donc le 24 août
1914 que le corps expéditionnaire entama
la fameuse retraite de mons avec la
première armée de vente look assez cool
ce jour là comme le premier jour ce
furent les hommes du 2e corps commandée
par le général speedo revient qui
subirent le plus fort de l'assaut et
demi sur le flanc gauche des
britanniques la 15e brigade fut attaqué
avec une violence particulière au nord
ouest du village des louches
le 1er régiment du shisha et un père 10
80 % de ses effectifs soit 800 officiers
et hommes de troupe sur les 1000 qui le
composaient et ce malgré un soutien
efficace des canons de la 119e place où
qu'ils se trouvent les éléments de
l'arrière garde britannique fut submergé
par des assaillants au nombre
considérable
ce lundi 24 août il y eut aussi des
engagements féroce à oujda pâturages et
tout spécialement à fram hier où la 9e
brigade qui s'étaient battus 6
héroïquement la veille au saillant de
mons fut attaqué par des forces
allemandes très supérieure
au total les britanniques période plus
d'hommes au premier jour de la retraite
qu'il en avait perdu pendant toute la
bataille de mons
seul john french se retrouva face à un
autre dilemme il pouvait en donner à ses
troupes de se réfugier dans la ville
fortifiée de maubeuge
c'était tentant pour le commandent une
arme est fatigué et beaucoup moins
nombreuses que l'ennemi mais franche
décida de continuer à battre en retraite
ce qui s'avèrera être une sage décision
mon but maubeuge et est un refuge qui
paraissait évident c'était une ville
fortifiée qui avait été bâti au siècle
précédent
il y avait des remparts il y avait
beaucoup de gens de l'eau de la
nourriture la possibilité de dormir
confortablement et on voulait facilement
la défendre mais c'était bien ce que
votre look espérer que les anglais
ferait en effet une fois entré un beau
buzz le corps expéditionnaire aurait été
prise au piège
même si une partie de l'armée
britannique aurait pu s'installer dans
la ville allemande d'ailleurs fait qu'un
justement bosque mais s'ils décident
d'aller à mon voeu le corps
expéditionnaire britannique sera très
vite encerclés détruit petit à petit il
sera hors d'état de nuire
il ne sera plus une force de combat dans
les allemands doivent tenir compte sur
jeunes fredj pour la bonne décision
les décide de continuer à battre en
retraite en coopération avec les
français et ne se laisse pas tenté par
la ville centre s il continue de reculer
en combattant afin d'aider à sauver
paris le soir du 24 août les soldats du
camp expéditionnaire arrive fourbus dans
le village de bavay l'objectif majeur
était de continuer à reculer jusqu'au
secteur du cateau cambrésis à 30 km de
là mais french décide de diviser ses
forces en deux la retraite du premier
corps se poursuit à l'est de la forêt de
mormal pendant que le deuxième corps
suit la voie romaine à l'ouest
aurait pu vouloir garder le corps
expéditionnaire en une seule unité
passant par la même route
mais s'il avait décidé cela il aurait
doublé et peut-être même tripler le
temps nécessaire pour la retraite parce
que trop d'hommes se seraient trouvés
sur scène seulement
c'est pourquoi même si les leçons sur du
faible ce qui peut l'être un risque
énorme à diviser ses forces il décida
qu'il n'y avait simplement pas d'autre
choix possible
le 25 août la retraite continue le
premier corps est engagé dans des
combats landrecies et maroilles pendant
ce temps le deuxième corps continuent à
avancer vers le cateau
il est renforcé par l'arrivée
d'angleterre des 10e 11e et 12e brigade
d'infanterie de la 3e division
ainsi que par la 19e brigade
d'infanterie le 25 ou sur john french
déplaçant quartier général du cateau
jusqu'à saint quentin au sud est
french ordonne à ses troupes de
continuer leur retraite pour rejoindre
cette nouvelle position
mais cette nuit alors que les allemands
continuent de l'attaqué sur son flanc
gauche
le général smith d'oriens décide
d'arrêter le recul est pour résister au
cateau cette décision courageuse mais
risqué a été longtemps critiquée par
certains
malgré les renforts qui les avaient
rejoints les hommes du 2e corps était
fatigué de se battre est épuisé on leur
demandait maintenant de faire face et de
combattre un ennemi beaucoup plus
nombreux beaucoup plus armé que celui
d'oriens quoique igraal rejoindre cateau
avec le premier corps
il décide donc de faire face et de
combattre pour briser l'élan des
mouvements allemands pensent que le
général frêche sera d'accord avec ce
mouvement de retard deux mois cet
endroit même si french indiqué qu'il
souhaitait que la recette se poursuivent
aussi vite que possible
six suisses de rien avait continué sa
retraite plutôt que de faire face le
combattre il aurait été rattrapé à
découvert dans la plaine france dans une
position de grande vulnérabilité
aurait-il dû continuer sa retraite ou
s'arrêter comme il l'a fait je pense que
l'histoire confirme que sa décision
était celle il fallait prendre ce me
dorion n'était pas stupide
les bataillons qui se décide à d'opposer
aux allemands n'avaient pas beaucoup
combattu au monde par contre les régimes
en 2005 des voyants puissiez tout ce qui
avait supporté le poids de la bataille
continue hier vers le sud
la position choisie par le deuxième
corps pour résister au cateau-cambrésis
n'étaient pas idéales
on était en plein sans possibilité de
protection particulière mis à part
quelques chants nombreux sonnés les
troupes n'ai pas eu le temps d'installer
un périmètre de défense correcte
enfin le dispositif britannique était
d'autant plus exposés
une élévation du terrain avec un bois
fournissent à l'infanterie allemande une
base idéale pour lancer ces attaques
la ligne de défense des troupes de smith
doria s'étendait depuis l'ouest du
cateau jusque vers village d'oô cours en
face de ce sont quatre divisions
d'infanterie allemande et 3 division de
cavalerie qui s'alignait en ordre de
bataille avec un support d'artillerie
importante
1 6 heures par un matin brumeux les
allemands ouvrir le feu depuis le
nord-est du cateau menaçant la cinquième
division britannique qui couvrait le
flanc est de la soul le plus violent
c'est la 4ème brigade qui était situé à
l'extrémité du dispositif qui a souffert
le plus car les forces allemandes ont
pris en tenaille par le nord le sud en
faisant pleuvoir un déluge de feu sur le
deuxième régiment du suffolk et le 2e
régiment de manchester
l'artillerie britannique fit de son
mieux pour ce pire ses troupes dès
canaux de 18 lits de la 28ème brigade
sera perfore sur l'ennemi
la 122e batterie fille pleuvoir les obus
sur la fonderie allemande qui s'avançait
il n'a qu'une fonction en 1914 la
différence principale qui existait entre
l'artillerie allemande et la britannique
était simplement que les allemands
avaient beaucoup plus de canaux à la
bataille de kato les allemands à
lignières 550 pièces contre les 228
canon britannique et la première partie
de la bataille c'est essentiellement un
duel d'artillerie
les britanniques on peut tenir leurs
positions défense à l'ouest du cateau
pendant toute la matinée la 7e brigade a
réussi à repousser une puissante attaque
des allemands à caudry encore plus à
l'ouest
la quatrième division qui venait
d'arriver sur le front pour renforcer le
deuxième corps recul à sa position pour
point d'orgue avec le reste de la ligne
de défense est protégé le flanc gauche
britannique la 11e brigade pris sous le
feu de l'artillerie allemande et des
attaques incessantes de l'infanterie est
parvenu à tenir bon malgré des pertes
très importantes
mais nos véritables problèmes pour les
britanniques se situer sur le flanc
droit à l'est où la supériorité de la
retirer allemand demandé la position
intenable à 13h45 à 14h brigade avait
plus d'autre alternative que de reculer
c'était déjà trop tard pour les
malheureux survivants du 11e régiment de
manchester et particulièrement pour le
deuxième régiment du suffolk à 14h30 il
était complètement encerclée mais il
continuer le combat jusqu'à la fin
l'extrémité du fond noir britanniques
étaient détruites
il fallut sonner la retraite du deuxième
corps à l'aise de la forêt de mormal à
moins de 10 kilomètres de là les hommes
du premier corps pouvait entendre de
fracas de la terrible bataille du cateau
mais ils ne purent porter assistance aux
régiments du suffolk en situation
critique
ax faire ce qu il y avait deux raisons
principales pour lesquelles le premier
corps de règles ne pouvait pas aller au
secours de celui de rien au cateau la
première était que reg lui même commence
et à subir la pression les attaques
allemandes
il y avait aussi un problème politique
et smith derrien entretenait de très
mauvaises relations et n'a pas voulu
courir au secours de deuxième corps sur
sa seule initiative et à penser comme le
pensent également sur john fraîche que
le premier corps allait lui aussi subir
une pression énorme les allemands inc
et puis il était pratiquement impossible
de faire faire demi-tour un corps
d'armée en quelques heures
west soliste industry awards
pendant les affrontements du cateau lieu
un très grand nombre d'actes individuels
de courage et d'héroïsme le majorié
degania sa victoria cros pour avoir mené
une charge désespérée contre les
assaillants allemand pour ralentir leur
avance le capitaine reynolds et deux de
ses hommes méritaient leur tour le plus
grand honneur militaire britannique en
récupérant la barbe des allemands un
obusier abandonné
malheureusement pour le corps
expéditionnaire le courage
extraordinaire d'hommes que le capitaine
reynolds n'a pas suffi au cateau
cambrésis vers la fin d'après midi
le deuxième corps fit de son mieux pour
s'extirper de la bataille battre en
retraite vers le sud
pendant que l'arrière garde composée de
fantassins du régiment du yorkshire
protéger courageusement la retraite de
ceux qui restent et la cinquième
division 1 3e division qui occupaient le
centre du dispositif se retirant suite
et finalement la quatrième division
décrocha avec l'aide d'un détachement de
cavalerie française
à la tombée de la nuit la retraite du
champ de bataille était terminée
l'avancée de l'armée allemande avait été
stoppé pendant un jour entier mais avec
un coût considérable puisqu'il 8000
soldats britanniques morts ou blessés
mais dorian été prise au piège il devait
stopper les allemands qui avance et
solide afin de permettre la majeure
partie du désaccord de son tir et quand
il a réussi son coup d'arrêt il a gagné
quelques heures jusqu'à la survie de son
corps le lendemain après avoir marché
encore une fois toute la nuit
c'est une troupe exténué du deuxième
corps qui arrive à saint quentin
mais il y avait encore des mauvaises
nouvelles pour les britanniques
un book de 2000 soldats 4e division
n'avait pas reçu l'ordre de mettre en
retrait et seulement la moitié d'entre
eux finalement pu trouver le moyen de
rejoindre le deuxième corps d'armée
même si les troupes du corps
expéditionnaire ne pouvait plus il
fallait continuer à battre en retraite
et par dessus tout à maintenir la
discipline
compte tenu des circonstances qui est
tout à fait remarquable c'est qu'un seul
cas où l'ordre aux militaires qui
pouvait menacer le soir du 27 ou en
plein centre de saint quentin un certain
nombre de soldats survivants de la
quatrième division décidèrent de refuser
de continuer à marcher mais il suffit d
efforts d'un seul homme
dans quelle situation soit résolue que
les disciplines règne à nouveau dans les
rangs
quand brigitte vaujany saint-quentin
elle retrouva sur la place principale de
cette petite ville
deux à trois cents hommes complètement
démotivée épuisé et pour la plupart
allongée à même leurs deux officiers
commandants des colonels étaient prêts à
se rendre
bridji ce vaillant cette débâcle en
train dans un magasin de jouets
accompagné par son trompette il trouve
un petit ton bon enfant bien sifflé à
roulettes
il revint vers tous ces hommes
complètement découragé st a lâché prise
de leur parla allez les gars venu avec
moi et pas question de se rendre et
siffla avec son sifflet à cadres sup
rendrait sont trop pen faisait rouler
son tambour et tous ces hommes épuisés
absolument mecs dénué les marchés depuis
mons on se bat en presque tout le temps
ce le vert et le suivirent grâce
notamment tom ridge is la totalité de ce
qui restait du deuxième corps a quitté
saint quentin aux premières heures du 28
août et la marche vers le sud continuent
à
en comparaison de ce qui s'était passé
depuis mons la suite du repli sur
presque paisible et les engagements avec
les allemands de vars beaucoup plus
rares le deuxième corps a rejoint l'oise
à noyon le 28 août et le 31
tout le clan l'armée avait traversé la
rivière et se diriger vers betts où il
fit enfin sa jonction avec les troupes
du premier corps
pendant cette période les seuls combats
qui ont lieu en un clic et la cavalerie
mais pour les fantassins moyens les
épreuves traversées pendant ces longs
jean d'été ont été particulièrement
éprouvants
au delà de l'effort physique il leur
fallu faire appel à toutes leurs
ressources mentales
il faisait très chaud les soldats
britanniques était fatigué a vite pas et
soif et continuent leur marche en
direction de paris kilomètre après
kilomètre écrasée par le poids de leur
paquetage et de leur art il n'avait que
très peu d'occasions de se reposer
vraiment et savait que chaque pas
supplémentaire les éloigner d'une armée
allemande qui semblait invincible
les allemands et c'est juste derrière
avec cette énorme machine de guerre qui
avait causé tellement de pertes aux
troupes britanniques aient eu penser que
tout ce qu'il ferait c'était fuir au
plus vite devant les allemands il ne
savait pas exactement ce progrès
français ni l'ennemi d'ailleurs il ne
savait même pas quand ils allaient
pouvoir manger où dormir
ils portaient les uniformes lourd et
épais dans les conditions d'un salaire
très difficile ce fut l'un des plus
beaux j'étais du xxème siècle quand il
avait de la chance ils pouvaient dormir
des nuits du 24 heures et leur
épuisement leur ai rarement mère était
la seule chose qui comptait dans leur
vie le deuxième corps continuer sa
marche vers le sud puis dans l'année
même du premier corps de règles malgré
un incident tragique le 27 août
quand deux compagnies du royaume en soi
fusiliers de la première division
certes anéantis au corps d'un engagement
féroce à être heureux à la fin du mois
d'août la quatrième division la 19e
brigade d'infanterie arrivèrent à
verberie
au soir du 31 août la première brigade
de cavalerie gagna les environs de néry
elle était accompagnée par la batterie
elle du régiment royal d'artillerie
tracter alors insu la quatrième division
de cavalerie allemands étaient également
arrivés dans le secteur dès le lendemain
matin le 1er septembre il eu un
engagement bref mais féroce entre les
deux forces ennemies pendant lesquelles
trois victorien cross de plus sur
décerné grâce l'artillerie britanniques
pris sous un feu roulant
la cavalerie allemande qui s'approchait
d'un canot tout particulièrement se
signala par la précision son tir qui
désorganise a complètement l'attaquent
des cavaliers et les force à se rebeller
c'était le canon du majeur bradbury mon
pneu qui fut mortellement blessé semé
service son arme avec ses 2es jusqu'à
son dernier souffle
tous trois reçu la victoria cross au
lèche les britanniques ne perdirent que
135 hommes mais la sphère couteau
également une division tout entière de
cavalerie le 1er septembre a été le
dernier jour où au lieu des engagements
importants avec les allemands à crépy en
valois et à villers cotterêts
le premier le deuxième corps dû
repousser des attaques sur leur arrière
garde
là encore les pertes britanniques et
allemandes ont été lourdes
au soir du 1er septembre les deux
composantes du corps expéditionnaire
fürth enfin réunis à betts et la fin de
la retraite en combattant était
maintenant en danger
le 3 septembre par une journée très
chaud de l'été finissant
l'armée meurtri traversa la marne et le
jour suivant arriva dans le secteur des
deux morin
c'est ce même jour que les alliés reçu
des nouvelles réconfortantes
concernant les mouvements du flanc droit
de l'armée allemande il avait longtemps
menacé l'ouest de paris pour tenter de
l'encercler mais la reconnaissance
aérienne britannique confirmant que la
première armée devant duclos qu'avait
changer de route et se dirigeait vers
l'est
john foster mais la première armée
allemande fait dirigeaient maintenant
vers le sud est de paris
enfin de mener la grande bataille gagnée
en tissement par laquelle l'armée
française est ce pas critiquer minuscule
corps expéditionnaire britannique et
chaque seraient détruits malheureusement
pour vonn cloud
les britanniques avaient fait une
retraite en bon ordre et franchit la
marne en 8es combattants capable de
cueillir imposition de plus votre look
n'est pas totalement sûr de la manière
dont l'armée française aux français sont
en train de masser nouvelle armée aux
environs de paris vers l'est vit comme
vonn cloud cachan et de roubles pour
avancer vers l'est de paris plutôt que
vers l'ouest son flanc droit est devenu
très vulnérable c'est cette faiblesse
que les alliés exploiteront pendant la
première bataille de la marne
le général gallieni qui était le
gouverneur militaire de paris voulait
absolument tirer parti de cette
possibilité qu'offrait le changement de
stratégie des allemands il persuada
joffre que sa 6ème armée
aidé par le corps expéditionnaire
britannique devait mener une contre
attaque camp joffre ordonne la contre
attaque sur la marque la garnison de
sarry organise des sorties pour attaquer
le coup droit de la première armée
allemand mais cela amène ses premières
armes et à devoir pivoter vers l'ouest
pour faire face à la menace 5
le 5 septembre un grand de retraite de
pim ans se terminer bien loin de la
petite ville belge l'essence
britanniques et allemandes s'étaient
rencontrés pour la première fois 13
auparavant
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
avait reculé de plus de 300 km en se
battant constamment contre un ennemi
très supérieurs en nombre et en
équipements
malgré la perte de plus de 15000 hommes
les britanniques étaient restés une
force organisée et capables de nous
battre
quelques jours plus tard il attaquer à
nouveau les nous dans cette bataille de
la marne qui annonçait le commencement
de la grande contre attaques alliées
deadwood street formant la retraite de
mon s'est déroulé en contact constant
avec l'ennemi c'est une situation
pratiquement unique dans les annales de
la guerre il n'y a jamais eu un nouveau
désengagement si fréquent avec des
forces ennemies très supérieurs pendant
une longue retraite dont l'armée en
retraite soit parvenu à se sortir
virtuellement intacte picchu la valeur
militaire de cette retraite est très
clair si les britanniques et les
français avaient décidé de combattre à
mon sens est un chat loi fin puis de
combattre et de convaincre encore il n'y
a aucun doute que les allemands les
heures est submergé
ne serait ce fait par leur supériorité
numérique et aurait finalement réussi à
prendre paris la retraite de mons a
donné naissance à l'une de ces légendes
persistant de l'histoire militaire
une interprétation haute en couleurs qui
confirme sans aucun doute à ce qui veut
bien y croire que dieu était du côté des
alliés à retraite de mons est une pilule
amère à avaler car le corps
expéditionnaire par le gouvernement
prendre les hommes politiques aussi par
la population de l'île
on a même été jusqu'à évoquer la légende
des orges descendu du ciel sur bon pour
nous aider à retenir leurs avions
allemands
sky journée le ciel et rougis par les
flammes de l'incendié de la ville de
mons et bien sûr les journalistes ont
pas cette image des archers du ciel qui
tirer sur l'ennemi depuis les nuages et
soudain c'est la bataille ça reste est
ce que les allemands vers 8h30 et 9h du
matin sonne la retraite avec leurs héros
ils ont doit c'est surtout le fond seuls
les clairons de la retraite
et quand on interroge des survivants ils
disent oui je lui cette histoire c'est
vrai je m'en souviens et la légende
continue
mais aujourd'hui plus de 90 ans plus
tard les magnifiques paysages français
et belge sont pleins de souvenirs de
ceux qui étaient une quinzaine
particulièrement crucial de l'histoire
militaire britannique et de celle de la
première guerre mondiale
on
m